thank you
[Music]
so have you guys
um you guys heard that Logan Paul has
made the transition
to a woman to the WWE okay never mind a
fish there's a lot of news bro I saw the
one like clip of him in it and he was
great good when he did the [__] when
are you doing all the flip-flops yeah
but didn't he already wrestled though so
like isn't that a part of his world we
call it wrestler yeah yeah that's a high
level right is way different than
acrobatics oh like he did flips and then
he got a chair and slapped somebody yeah
like he like all of those crazy back
flips jumping like 10 feet in the air
like that's way different or to like do
a whole wrestling match like for the
first time is like it was just
choreographed you know what I mean so
that's like totally different nah dude
that's just real yeah I never mentioned
that uh you did uh wrestling in college
to me when we were hanging out
[Laughter]
cool guy yeah very I actually you really
like them I do it's pretty likable on
podcasts yeah yeah he's the hardest
worker that I uh met in a long time his
drink company is with UFC yeah Prime
which is pretty cool how is it with the
UFC now they are it's the official drink
uh hydration
it's honestly the prime contract
can get Zoe in there huh do you like the
amount of um the the sugars is low and
all that kind of stuff yeah yeah it's
really good electrolytes I think it's
great it tastes good it looks like
you're a bang boy nah not like that only
in a pinch but only when I really need
some caffeine
for 300 milligrams though sometimes your
boy just needs 300 million oh his drink
isn't an energy drink what is happening
it's a Gatorade thing yeah yeah but you
know he released the energy drink yeah
yeah it's pretty good what happened to
Vitamin Water I don't see that ever 50
cent's not promoting it no more do you
think he sold the company yeah he did I
think he made a good amount of money
art water remember Jan Anderson and then
they got the chick from Spider-Man's to
do it now I like the bottles yeah yeah
oh you know how I know marketing works
on me I get smart water because it fits
in my backpack better because it's
longer and skinnier but then I see
there's the blue one and then there's
the black one and because that one's
like ph9 or alkaline you're like I'll
tell you I don't even know what that
means I'm like alkaline is better than
me
telling the checkout guy I don't even
know what it does I'm like it's the same
stuff that's in batteries that's got to
be good I think smart water tastes good
compared to like the Sani Arrowhead bro
Dasani takes like [__] toilet water I
don't
want I don't like the bottle it not like
to drink it oh yeah yeah I do okay
um Dasani film s
come on I'm gonna show you guys a clip
or we can talk about bottled water
bottle of water
this is Logan Paul and some are calling
this the greatest wrestling move in the
history of wrestling he made up a new
move let's see
what is it called what is it called it's
a big [__] too wow oh oh that's
[__] cool slime dude see you can't do
that's not you don't do that [__] at
wrestling collisions [__] crazy
that's a close line from Hell brother
gcw they did that and then flipped both
of them yeah that was crazy so both of
them were taken to the ambulance after
that and then they put neck braces on
them both oh
beat them up in the house
and then Stone Cold was in the hospital
punching him and he came off the top of
a shelf and just like went through the
hospital bed and they plugged the
[__] IV bag and everything it's crazy
that's [__] up wd's WWE is in a
different world I can't believe they let
him do Libre the other day so good and I
was like [__] dude this movie was so so
good it's so good yeah and then the
Anaconda squeezed I was like man that
move is classic I don't remember that
movie you don't remember not to leave it
at all not even go go away read some
books I don't think I saw them once I
saw year one it took place in my memory
of that oh yeah oh no three
things
guys it's good summon your Eagle powers
where did you watch it on what's
streaming it didn't work I uh watching
on Amazon Joe if you had a wrestling
finishing movement
it had to be something racist Joe's
wrestling finish
called the cream pie oh I like that
it'd be a little racist because then I
really miss how everything used to be a
Trope about a culture you know like
something Japanese well then call it the
Japanese skate and eat oh I like it the
Japanese or the the [__]
what does that mean anything like pour
it all over so you could I could come
all over the face so it's not wrestling
anymore so yes you're literally doing it
I thought the calculus [__] on the chest
all right
so so is this Joe's move
dude come on wriggle dude
he's gonna kiss his ass yeah he's gonna
kiss his ass too he's like gumbo Vince
McMahon's so [__] funny oh he even
took off his [__] underwear too this
is
dude this is America right here dude
it's so funny bro this is why our
country is the best this is why I think
I think WWE is a great litmus test for
humor you really take this too seriously
like bro when I was a kid I used to
think this [__] was so [__] real bro
it is real bro it is like the story
lines like oh I used to be so mad all
the time when I used to watch how long
are they gonna take to kick his kisses
chapstick that's [__] funny dude who
are the writers of the WWE and the way
he's like troubled like oh no he's
actually putting on in a [__] suit
he's dreading at the whole side and this
is from the attitude I think Aaron
Sorkin The Attitude Era is our [__]
wait who's gonna be that's William Regal
does it dude that's the best this is our
North Star so stupid this is where we
gotta get to yeah
they're so good at milking it there
that's nothing they know they got like a
15 minute segment that's the thing and
then they break the commercial look at
this
look at this [__] mouth dude oh
oh you got it dude that's Joe's move but
Joe sucking come out of the guy's ass
after he finishes inside of them
do you guys see that one where the guy
his hand becomes a [__] snake yeah
that's mankind dude yes there's another
one too I don't know if it was WWE but a
guy goes and grabs his dick and then the
dick [__] him up oh yeah the guy just
uses his dick yeah
dude
in the Facebook move it was like the
that one guy he would like get a guy on
the turnbuckle and he's laying down and
the guy's like laying down like this
yeah and then the guy like does a flying
scissor kick and just like like bounces
his his legs off the guy's face like
with his cross like touches the guy's
face for a second he goes like this wow
and then he keeps on going he rides his
face yeah he rides his face I like that
one I think it's a Japanese wrestler but
it's he's just invisible have you seen
that what so he's just an invisible
wrestler so everyone has to play along
like he's in the ring
or they're pinning an invisible partner
yeah yeah but he's basically he's there
he's the second that guy's the sickest
game yo that wrestling match that you
took us to that was so fun we gotta go
again that's a great job I didn't get to
go it's a great you would do you would
eat it up get your [__] stapled to his
forehead I'm a [__] crazy I love it
it was so good and the fact that you as
a spectator could get [__] up if you
don't move yeah we were [__] honestly
screaming it was crazy yeah it's too bad
I love that stuff pull the [__] a
stapler out of his [__] backpack
after we go we gotta ask whatever
wrestler we love the best to come here
and do the show yeah because they would
be down dude they're great yeah who's
your favorite wrestler out of that show
cartwheel Jack cartwheel Jack was hella
sick all of his moves are cartwheel
based like all the Slime and like he
starts off he'll do like a cartwheel and
then his mission is to make the opponent
like caught with he's like come on you
do it and he goes oh no I don't want it
no but then somewhere in the match he'll
throw him and make the guy quite well
he'll go
get him more fired up
or Grim reefer is a great character but
he didn't come out we're the one that
gets stoned yeah Grim Reaper is just
this dude looks like a regular Stoner
guy he gets his ass whooped the whole
match at some point he'll be like on his
like death bed just basically laying
there the other guy's like yeah and then
he pops up and he's got a lit blunt and
just goes puff of smoke and then
everyone goes crazy because he's just
about to just destroy the guy and it's
so funny first yeah dude these gimmicks
man I love when Hulk Hogan was getting
his [__] ass wrecked in the ring and
then all of a sudden he just like
brother here you go and then yeah oh
yeah
no no no no no no no no no no no yeah
this this right here is everything
and then and then you could punch Hulk
like you were the whole match and he's
just like
every time you hit him he just gets
stronger I just love the playing along
it's like the way that you hoped your
dad would play along with you when
you're a kid it's the same like look up
on the some of the best compilations to
ever watch is like the top 10 botched
moments in the WWE where guys will like
the cue is he's supposed to clothesline
him out the [__] ring and he doesn't
do it or he doesn't fly over and then
he'll just throw himself out and it's
like so obvious because they [__] up
it's great is the number one moment that
one dude something Jack character Cactus
Jack no not Cactus Jack he was like an
ECW guy
something Jack yeah saboo where'd you do
this it's always the number one botch
where like so uh he he was just crazy he
was one of those ECW guys that loves to
like bleed but eventually in this one
match he just takes out a like the other
guy wasn't following his commands so he
got mad so he took out an actual knife
and just stabbed the dude 12 times
I don't know that one what the [__] was
it Chris Benoit dude hold on video it's
all on video yeah so he so he stabs a
guy oh no it's actual like there's
documentaries and everything oh [__]
yeah because he stabbed him and this
dude's he's still around to give
interviews today about it but he's not
dead no the guy didn't die and and uh
the guy waved the charges in order to
make Jack become his mentor
shut the [__] up dude Mentor in the
storyline or in real life this is real
life he was like can you guide me as a
wrestler what then I'll drop the charger
but the guy tried to kill him I know
[__] exactly was he trying to kill him
you're just crazy as [__] yeah he's
crazy he's nuts
cause at least you'd be maybe it's like
hey dude I thought that was the spring
knife I cannot [__] believe this [__]
you know I mean like maybe that's wild
but instead he's like
this guy yeah it's a crazy dude we gotta
look that up you're my hero it's nuts I
can't believe my biggest Hero trying to
kill me yeah and it was a it was like an
audience was there and everything it's
all on video still he's crazy the honest
one I thought was just like wrestling
that's not even his only thing that he
tried where he tried to kill somebody
either he's done multiple things where
like you know when they go on the top of
the rafters and stuff like he's done
stuff where like uh they're supposed to
throw this guy onto a stack of tables
and he purposely tried to like miss it
to kill the guy and the guy didn't die
but he admits today he's like yeah I was
trying to kill him whoa [__] dude is it
because he's trying to like make history
in the wrestling he might just be like
oh ECW was known as the hardcore [__]
ECW was crazy what oil